[Musica]
zampagna
e qui fermato per me certo buon viaggio
aperto polvere
come va
ionio
guardare un biglietto che è successo in
aeroporto allora praticamente
c'era la coda partitina
si chiamano marina marina
erano mia ex compagna di università e
qui va tutto bene salutare il tutto
certo punto era un ragazzo ti guarda i
fab
ti ricordi ti porti liguri
io
ricordavo cioè mi sembrava molto
io però non ho collegato
ragazzi
la storia
maria de filippi muta
io proprio col compagna le solo allora
me l'ha raccontato re perché il lavoro
no
gallipoli 2011 io lavoravo di barga
c'era anche questa ragazza
insomma diversità in vacanza
quindi ogni tanto ci si incontrava nei
locali e nei bar
a un certo punto è evidente 20 io ho
conosciuto
con questo ragazzo
lei con cui è la somma adesso
e
e adesso scambiati quel dato
un'associazione semplicemente amicizia
specie di essere ascoltati mi sembra che
ricordare a chi sceglierà di milano
finita lì
poi cosa è successo in questa maniera
aveva conosciuto in discoteca
cesa
solo che
e non siano scambiati
è il portato perché quindi
questa beva di lei
e già questo è l'inizio proprio di
un ragazzo
a trovarla scritto certo brillante
grazie a dio
grazie
perché l'ha trovata
tra i nemici facebook ha scritto sono
che non ci sono
io avevo sorrisi ed è uscito il profilo
di questa
sapete da molto tempo stanno insieme
provate a immaginare
otto anni ragazzi infatti gli ho chiesto
ma chi c'è non può ancora essere vietata
alle nozze perché è grazie a me che
scadesse va beh dopo questo episodio
a chiacchierare qualcuno salvo ma vi
prometto che
vi faccio vedere scesi dall'aereo ti
faccio a salutare da questa coppia più
prima
allora ci hanno scattato delle polaroid
veramente carine
ce n'è una che sembra tipo compleanno
anni 90
delle medie questo bellissimo
io sono quello sbarazzino e il proprio
il programmino in questo punto
fa queste palermo
stavo facendo photo shooting video qua
insomma nel baretto che c'è qui
io avevo tutto restano ancora mai tutto
rossetto sui denti o perfetto lui
sorride ed è falso salvatore
chi aveva tutto
calcio
e a mangiando
spalmato sui denti sempre facendo del
defunto veramente da brescia robert un
amen
meno male che ci siamo accorti adige
dove sono poi corazzate perché davanti a
tutti insomma la più di eminenti sociale
in fondo meglio
ancora
[Musica]
allora che cosa ha fatto una vita ha
raccontato la storia nel nord e quindi
mi hanno chiesto di fare vedere insomma
si erano presentati dopo dopo un'ora di
volo non sta tanto tranquilla anche solo
tremenda comunque loro stanno insieme da
otto anni da sette anni grazie
vabbè diciamo sì quindi alle nozze
vogliamo esserci vi invitiamo a segnare
la svolta
[Musica]